at the beginning of john wick the
titular character's wife helen
is already dead she lives in the film as
a memory
which the main character played by keanu
reeves is determined to keep alive
within himself
for instance near the start of the movie
john watches a video of helen
on his phone taken during a trip to the
beach when they were happy together
most of what audiences learn about helen
wick comes from hearing what jon was
willing to do for her
jon had been an assassin but left this
life behind
before their marriage completing an
impossible task in order to get out
without strings attached
when her death from a terminal illness
was imminent helen arranged for a puppy
to be delivered to jon as a way to help
him deal with his grief
and find something else to love
tragically that doesn't end well either
but it's undeniable that the actress
playing john wick's wife
bridget moynihan makes quite the
impression
here's why helen from john wick looks so
familiar
after entering the public eye thanks to
her work as a model
moynihan's first big acting role came on
the second season of hbo's
sex in the city she played natasha a
young woman that mr big meets in paris
when he's not dating series protagonist
carrie bradshaw
much to carrie's dismay big not only
chooses natasha
instead of her but he also goes ahead
and marries the new woman
something he hadn't seemed to consider
in his relationship with carrie
but after their marriage big admits to
carrie that he made a mistake
and the pair begin to have an affair
with him cheating on natasha
and carrie cheating on her boyfriend
aiden eventually
natasha discovers them chasing after
carrie and
breaking her tooth in the process the
event leads to carrie calling off the
affair
but the damage has already been done to
big and natasha's marriage
the pair ultimately get divorced ending
moynihan's unforgettable time on the
show
moynihan's biggest blockbuster role came
in the 2004 science fiction blockbuster
irobot
she portrayed susan calvin a
robo-psychologist who helps robot hating
detective del spooner
played by will smith investigate a death
that might have been caused by a robot
unfortunately robots repeatedly attack
the pair
as they investigate and they eventually
uncover a much larger conspiracy
in the form of a plot by a rogue central
computer
only a few elements of the film i robot
are based on isaac asimov's collection
of short stories
of the same name but moynihan's role is
one of them
the character appeared in much of
asimov's robot themed fiction
serving as chief robo psychologist at
the manufacturing company u.s robots and
mechanical men
inc and was often portrayed as a
brilliant if
coldly logical scientist lately the best
place to see moynihan has been on the
cbs procedural drama blue bloods
where she plays aaron the only daughter
of new york city police commissioner
frank reagan
played by tom selleck while her brothers
danny
jamie and the deceased joe followed
their father into the family business of
policing
aaron reagan decided to become a new
york county assistant district attorney
any character on a show that's been
running for 11 seasons will have seen
her fair share of
ups and downs and aaron is no different
she's had a variety of love interests
since divorcing her husband jack boyle
played by peter herman
however some of aaron's potential love
interests were either the district
attorney
or would eventually take on the role
making them her boss
she's watched her daughter nikki played
by sammy gale grow up
multiple times she's had to be saved by
members of her family
meaning that there's never a dull moment
on the show blue blood's
busy network drama schedule which has
seen more than 220 episodes to date
has kept moynihan busy for the better
part of a decade
with her appearing in only a handful of
other film roles during that time
these include battle los angeles
midnight sun
crown vic and two of the three john wick
movies that have been released
thus far perhaps that's why a gig as
john wick's wife was especially
appealing as it was something small that
wouldn't require much of a time
commitment from moynihan who is already
very busy starring on a successful tv
show
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one